[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
cyclisme le départ de la 76e édition du
paris-nice a été donné depuis les
yvelines ce dimanche le français arnaud
démare a remporté la première étape
entre château et me do au bout du
suspense aujourd'hui les coureurs se
sont élancés depuis le petit village
d'orson ville tous les détails sur ce
paris-nice illinois source de cette
fuite sport handball plaisir à réaliser
la très belle opération de ce week-end
en surclassant le leader saint polois
sur le score de 28 à 21
victoire qui leur permet de revenir à un
point de la première place les détails
dans ce magazine
insolite le championnat de france de
bras de fer s'est déroulée ce samedi à
vélizy villacoublay
une centaine de joueurs venus de toute
la france a participé à ce rendez vous
où massue dans quelques instants
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par la 76e
édition du paris nice pour la 9e année
consécutive le peloton s'est élancé ce
dimanche 4 mars depuis les yvelines le
départ a été donné depuis la ville de
chatou un département qui réussit au
nouveau chouchou du public français
arnaud démare 26 ans qui s'est entraîné
la semaine précédente au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le coureur de la groupama fdj vainqueur
l'année dernière à bois d'arcy s'est de
nouveau illustré en remportant la
première étape au bout du suspense il
devance de quelques millimètres à la
photo finish l'espagnol gorka izaguirre
le sportif tentera sûrement de réaliser
la passe de 3 l'année prochaine en
revenant dans les yvelines
au-delà de l'aspect à sportif le paris
nice est également un engouement
populaire comme chaque année les
supporteurs ont répondu présent pour
encourager les 154 coureurs malgré des
conditions climatiques difficiles
des images de nicolas d'henri un montage
de romain aarhus fini ni le froid ni le
vent ni la pluie ont découragé les
aficionados du paris nice is it et plus
d'une centaine de supporters avoir fait
le déplacement pour approcher les 150 4
coins sur l'île des impressionnistes de
chatou pour le départ de cette 76e
édition
les voir en vrai voire de l'organisation
de sa tour
beaucoup de fans c'est un peu la fête du
vélo moi je fais du vélo pour le plaisir
donc puis c'est l'occasion pour les
enfants aussi devoir tout l'équipement
et puis c'est un peu la fête
c'est sympa même si c'est vrai que les
conditions météo sont pas sympas un
enthousiasme du public qui ne décline
pas depuis la signature de la convention
yvelines paris nice en 2010 ce succès ne
surprend pas l'organisation
c'est un département qui est juste à
côté de paris
parier là et en même temps c'est la
forêt c'est la campagne d'affilée à tout
pour pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement avec les années sur le
vélo cette année le chouchou c'est lui
julian alaphilippe pour son troisième
paris nice le coureur français de 25 ans
a pu voir sa cote de popularité grandir
auprès du grand public
si vous
allez je veux dire même sens ça fait
plaisir ouais on est prêt pour la
première étape on va donner le maximum
ça me crois qu'on aime on est ma passion
qui couvre son panache sa façon de voir
la course
ouais qu'il ait toujours au bout de
lui-même qu'il essaye toujours d'attaqué
de gagner
voilà saint paul qui va gagner des
grandes courses stade année c'est sûr
julian alaphilippe pourra continuer à
conquérir le coeur du public heavy noie
dans les prochaines années
le partenariat entre les organisateurs
du paris nice et les yvelines s'étend
jusqu'en 2021 les yvelinois se sont
déplacés nouvelle fois en nombre dans le
sud des yvelines pour le départ de la
deuxième étape depuis or son vilain
village de moins de 400 habitants qui
accueillait pour la toute première fois
de son histoire les preuves
notre journaliste nicolas landry était
sur place il a pu interroger ce midi sur
la ligne de départ la maire de la
commune anne cabri sur l'organisation
d'un tel événement les coureurs du
paris-nice son parti d'orson ville ici
il ya quelques minutes maintenant et
anne cabrié a donné le départ avec ce
drapeau un cabri vous êtes la mère
d'orson ville alors qu'est ce quelle
sensation vous avez eu en ce coin ce
drapeau pour libérer les coureurs une
grande fierté pour notre village une
grande fierté pour le département des
yvelines une grande fierté pour la
ruralité
oui on est heureux d'accueillir ce
départ dans le plus petit village de
départ de l'histoire du paris nice
alors c'est le départ de la deuxième
étape entre or sont villé et vierzon 104
plus de 180 km pour les coureurs
vous aviez arnaud démare et pierre luc
périchon à côté de vous le maillot jaune
et le maillot à pois
quelles sensations que vous avez eue
quand vous étiez à côté c'est une joie
d'être avec deux grands sportifs dont le
maillot jaune et le maillot à pois
voilà on sort on est toutes humble à
côté d'eux parce que c'est quand même
les gros sportif c'est eux qui vont
arriver jusqu'à vierzon
je pense bien que cette étape
aujourd'hui est fait pour arnaud démare
on en a discuté tous les deux il a
toutes les conditions et c'est vraiment
j'espère une course de plus aujourd'hui
pour lui alors de départ qui a remporté
la première étape entre chatou et meudon
alors or the horse on vit le c400
habitants finalement là vous étiez
quasiment il y avait plus de l'île
habitants aujourd'hui
ben oui on a quasiment tripé la
population donc c'est c'est très très
bien
je suis très heureuse pour
les habitants pour tous les gens qui
sont venus nous voir pour les amoureux
du sport c'était une très belle journée
en plus c'est la course du soleil et
vous voyez le soleil était sort son vide
ce matin
et du coup est-ce que quel retour vous
avez de la population qu'est-ce qui vous
ont dit là dans les quelques minutes
après le départ il était très surpris
il est très en fait et bailly il savait
plus qu à dire parce que dans un petit
village un événement aussi gigantesques
ils sont sur le voilà mais on va se
remettre de ses émotions
c'était quand même un très beau moment
et voilà très heureuse d'avoir pu
accueillir et j'espère que l'an prochain
un autre maire à ma place au ratio
recommencé ce matin
quelle image vous garderez de ce départ
une grande humilité un grand
professionnalisme de aso tout s'est
passé vraiment dans le sens populaire du
terme je garderai un bon bonne matinée
où tous les gens se sont retrouvés
les gens pris leur journée c'est le jour
de la journée aujourd'hui de la rentrée
des classes pour l'île de france et on
se rend compte en fait bien que tout le
monde était là c'est un bon moment comme
je les aime on mange à leurs hôtes le
monde on se congratule pour le sport
alors anne perry est ce que vous avez un
chouchou avait parlé d' arnaud démare
c'est votre chouchou bien tony gallopin
également donc j'espère qu'il va
également peut-être pouvoir gagner ce
paris nice je lui souhaite vraiment
plein de bonnes choses et puis bon tous
les autres bien évidemment parce que on
est humble par rapport à ses grands
coureurs uni félicitations alors voilà
les coureurs ont quitté donc le
département des yvelines et le
département des yvelines qui sera aussi
au coeur du championnat de france de
cyclisme prévue en juin prochain
après un périple de 187 5 km 10 jan
groen wengen s'est imposé au sprint à
vierzon le français a mené ma 5e reste
lui en tête du classement général
un mot de cyclisme sur piste à présent
les pistards français qui s'entraîne
quotidiennement vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'ont pas
brillé lors des championnats du monde
d'apeldoorn aux pays bas ils n'ont
remporté que deux médailles de bronze la
semaine dernière le prodige de 21 ans
sébastien vigier a réussi à terminer
troisième en vitesse individuelle ce
côté les niveaux 1 françois pervis a
remporté une médaille de bronze en
vitesse par équipes avec les deux
illinois sébastien vigier encore lui et
michael d'almeida lille 7e médaille
mondiale pour le pistard mais pas de
huitième couronne son objectif avant à
ces championnats du monde
hameau des jo de 2024 à paris la
compétition se prépare déjà au niveau
des instances six mois avant l'événement
planétaire
l'athlète paralympique maintenant à
keita championne du 400 mètres
malvoyants à rio en 2016 est ancienne
l'aide de l'ue à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 21 gré le
comité d'organisation des jeux de 2024
la sportive qui travaille toujours à
montigny le bretonneux chez malakoff
médéric vient d'être désigné par le
président tony estanguet dans ce comité
elle siégera aux côtés de l'ancien
athlète marie josé pérec du biathlète
martin fourcade de l'ancien tennisman
guy forget de la boxe sarah ourahmoune
les athlètes participeront notamment
grandes phases de planification de ce
rendez vous olympique parisien du
handball à présent dans ce magazine
plaisir a signé l'exploit du week-end
dans les yvelines
en nationale 3 les plaisirs watts
deuxième du championnat réussi à
renverser le leader saint polois dans
leur gymnase lors de la 13e journée
victoire acquise avec brio 28 à 21 dans
une ambiance électrique
un résultat qui leur permet de pointer à
un petit point de la première place et
de la montée mais coûte l'entraîneur du
club de victor gariepy comment ne pas
vraiment vraiment un grand moment un
très très bon niveau
[Musique]
le père thomas peut-être à dire l'armée
par un moment donné avant et avec une
belle manière vraiment prochain match
pour plaisir le samedi 17 mars sur le
terrain du 6e plus tôt en rugby ont joué
elle sourit qu'elle la 17e journée du
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir
presque assuré du maintien n'a pas
brillé face au leader rennes les
plaisirs wa 10e du championnat ont
lourdement chuté sur leur talent devant
leur public 59 à 7 dans un match à sens
unique
une défaite logique comme nous l'ont
confié les supporters de plaisir à la
mi-temps micro de nicolas landry ce
match en particulier est déséquilibrée
puisque rennes est l'équipe en tête du
classement et
comment dire avec des moyens qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ceux de plaisir la
différence elle est sur le plan
technique individuelle collective et
puis la préparation physique aussi on
voit bien que dans leurs placements les
joueurs de plaisir en plus de mal que
sereine dans les regroupements et on
vient d'avoir six ou sept joueurs comme
un plaisir avec deux deux joueurs et
après ça fait la différence en défense
et en attaque aussi donc plaisir se
consomme trop dans les rucks après ce
match plaisir est la dixième place du
championnat avec un bilan de 3 victoires
et 13 défaites depuis le début de la
saison on continue par un résultat de
basket dans la poule g du championnat de
nationale 3 le fc trappes s'est incliné
à domicile que ce week-end contre caen
basket calvados le score 72 à 68 une
contre-performance qui devrait remettre
devait mettre un terme aux espoirs de
montée du club saint quentinois qui
compte aujourd'hui quatre points de
retard sur le premier but il ya cinq
journées de la fin du championnat
prochain match dimanche prochain pour
dimanche prochain sur le terrain du
troisième quand asptt on ouvre une page
sport automobile la 28e édition du
rallye aïcha des gazelles une
compétition 100 % féminine s'élancera le
samedi 17 mars contre depuis nice en
direction du maroc
parmi les centaines de participants une
équipe composée de deux illinoise nadia
al harbi originaire d'abbeville et
isabelle rouge rosso d'orge russe de
communes du sud du département et nous
avons la chance de les recevoir sur son
plateau bonsoir alors ce sera une grande
première pour vous pourquoi vous êtes
vous lancé dans cette aventure
alors tout simplement parce que dans un
état d'esprit sportif
en ce qui me concerne les biens je me
suis dit que ça changerait peut-être
d'un sport que j'ai l'habitude de faire
qui est le golfe
et là c'est peut-être un défi pour
intégrer le milieu de l'automobile et
puis partir à l'aventuré
voilà dans le milieu du désert vous avez
rêvé noter que votre partenaire
et oui c'est une compétition soit
sportive mais c'est aussi un projet que
j'ai depuis longtemps j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de mettre à profit
nadir est venu me chercher donc voilà je
les remercie pour ça donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion et en fait moi ça me permet
aussi de
de me lancer des petites challenge des
défis voir si je peux aller jusqu'au
bout et puis sortir de ma zone de
confort voilà qui est intéressant
également ses goûts que vous connaissez
que depuis le mois de septembre depuis
exactement aussi un challenge c'est tout
simplement parce que nos enfants se
connaissent à l'origine et qu'en parlant
des mamans respectives
ils nous ont expliqué enfin ils se sont
expliqués d'un et l'autre que les mamans
avaient ce projet depuis un certain
nombre d'années
donc j'ai fait la démarche tout
simplement en appelant isabelle et on
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré en septembre
justement vous êtes soutenus par votre
entourage à nos proches vous a poussé à
vous inscrire oui exactement c'est à
dire que bon je pense que c'est une
aventure qu'on va faire certainement une
fois peut-être pourquoi pas deux fois
dans notre vie et où quelqu'un on a
besoin en effet d'un soutien au niveau
de notre famille parce que c'est quand
même beaucoup d'investissement de
au niveau de notre temps de notre
personne et tolérant oui voilà il arrive
à nous comprendre
quelquefois c'est pas facile parce que
on est beaucoup à l'extérieur très
sollicités puisque du fait de la
recherche de sponsors
automatiquement on a besoin de faire de
la représentation et ça prend beaucoup
de temps
justement cette recherche de sponsors la
compétition coûte plusieurs milliers
d'euros il faut un véhicule également
ça n'a pas trop été compliqué pour vous
2 réunira les fonds nécessaires mais je
dois dire que nous on a été assez
chanceuse on a un bon réseau donc les
sponsors ont répondu présent assez
rapidement et donc on a pu atteindre
notre notre budget faire un minimum
on s'était fixé rapidement c'est pour ça
qu'en décembre on a pu s'inscrire
de septembre à décembre on a réuni notre
budget donc là vraiment ils ont j'étais
avec nous et on a réussi un petit
challenge
donc on va parler la compétition
maintenant vous connaissez depuis sept
ans je le disais précédemment pour la
compétition n'aurait pas de gps
oui je devais affronter des épreuves
sans gps sans carte un potentiel comment
vous allez faire
et bien parce que c'est compliqué alors
compliqué non je pense qu'il faut avoir
beaucoup de réflexion et puis prendre du
recul et être très assagi parce que on a
juste des cartes qu on nous remet et une
boussole devrait car tout est dans une
vraie carte géographique qui sont sûres
du 1 25000e ou du 1 cent millième à
partir de là on doit trouver nos points
de latitude et de longitude qui nous
permet d'avoir un axe et à partir de là
avec notre boussole
on doit s'orienter pour justement trouvé
les bon axe les bons les bonnes
trajectoires pour permettre d'arriver à
des à trouver des balises
voilà ce sera le pilote et le co pilote
sont pas encore déterminées
ses paris sur lucky qui se débrouille le
mieux
en général c'est vrai que ça se définit
avec moi là c'est la presse qui est dit
et avec l'expérience à ceux définis oui
au fur et à mesure des jours qui passent
peut-être qu'il y en a une qui s'affirme
beaucoup plus pour justement de la
navigation et l'autre est peut-être
beaucoup plus
je dirais se retrouve dans un commandant
un contexte où est ce qu'elle peut
manipuler son véhicule après voilà c'est
vraiment prendre un changement qu'on a
toutes les deux néanmoins fait le stage
de pilotage et le stage de navigation
stage de navigation qui est obligatoire
pour participer au rallye
quand vous êtes s'entraîner du coup
depuis eh ben on a fait le stage de
navigation on fait des exercices qu'on
nous donne n'ont pas toutes les semaines
non non non non parce qu'on travaille qu
est-ce qu on n'a pas le temps de tout
faire on a fait deux stages de pilotage
de pilotage 1
du côté de la rochelle de la rochelle et
on
el manar violon tant aimé non vie pour
pour justement
ben ça affine et ne connaître le milieu
de sable oui à la compétition se passera
en hors piste quels sont les pièges à
éviter
le relief surtout puisque ce que l'on
nous dit c'est qu'ils sont changeants
donc on peut trouver des zones de sable
des zones de cailloux et l'herbe à
chameaux les rachats mais souhaite aussi
voilà les oueds qui peuvent être donc
c'est ce trait à sécher ou alors une
vision qu'on pourrait avoir du fait
qu'ils souhaitent à sécher et que
finalement cela supposerait humide
voilà et qui ferait que le véhicule sans
s'enliserait automatique donc les pièges
ceylan sablage la crevaison par les
cailloux voilà savoir que la crevaison
comme d'isabelle au niveau du règlement
sportif on doit on ne peut demander
aucune aide à part bon un équipage qui
passe parce qu'il ya une certaine forme
de solidarité mais sinon il est vrai que
on doit se débrouiller totalement on ne
doit pas appeler l'assistance ni pour
désensabler ni pour changer une roue
dans la question est ce qu'on pensait
faire un résultat là bas au maroc
on espère oui on espère mais voilà on
s'est tous natifs peut-être déjà
peut-être dans la première moitié mais
c'est tout c'est le débat après on va se
donner les moyens
les moyens de réussir tout le monde a sa
chance donc on est sur place on va
donner le meilleur de nous mêmes voilà
voilà
le tout c'est de se faire plaisir et
faire de son mieux les deux dépassé sur
ce plat qu il soit de terminer le plus
haut possible sur cette compétition je
vous rappelle que le départ sera donné
le 17 mars depuis nice le retour sera
soit 2 enfin le retour sera du maroc et
lui est prévue le 1er avril la direction
à vélizy villacoublay à présent les
championnats de france de bradfer à
sportif était organisée ce week-end dans
la ville pour la quatrième fois coup de
projecteur sur cette discipline qui
compte une soixantaine de licenciés en
ile-de-france des images de nicolas
d'enrayer moynier légèrement point des
poignets là vous êtes bon niveau je
t'annonce à la table
prouver que le bras de fer est un vrai
sport l'objectif de ce quatrième
championnat de france organisé ce samedi
3 mars dans la commune de vélizy
villacoublay
pour cela deux arbitres assistent au
match et font appliquer des règles
codifiées par les américains au siècle
dernier
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif pas du bras de fer de
comptoir pour vos poignets soit bien
droit que votre quête tôt ce matin fait
que vous ayez les poules bien en face
que vous soyez dans l'axé médian de la
table pour que les règles de ce sport
soit entièrement respectée les arbitres
n'hésite pas à lier les participants
tout simplement parce qu'en fait il ya
eu un lâcher de faisans pas réussi à
terminer le combat entre temps en prison
sur la table la testostérone et autour
du biceps ne font pas tout chaque ferry
se doit s'échauffer plusieurs minutes
avant son passage et surtout avoir une
stratégie pour remporter la victoire
intérieur ça veut dire en fait on passe
intérieure on reste groupé et en tire
comme ça et extérieur on utilise la
rotation jugé ans et plus
comme ça la force est au service de la
technique et non la force qui remplace
la technique vous avez des gens qui pour
d'autres disciplines sont des gens très
puissants mais quand vous les mettez
surtout ils ont un petit niveau de
résistance mais apprennent et non pas la
technique ils ont un peu perdu
cet événement permettra peut-être
d'attirer de nouveaux licenciés pour ce
sport encore confidentiel qui compte
seulement 200 pratiquants france et une
trentaine dans les yvelines
on passe maintenant la torre rubrique
agenda
[Musique]
de la boxe dans cet agenda et plus
précisément de la boxe anglaise féminine
un cours d'initiation est organisée ce 8
mars au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin à montigny le bretonneux dans
le cadre de la journée internationale de
la femme pour nous parler de ce rendez
vous nous recevons sur ce plateau alban
bennacer l'un des encadrements sur ce
projet et audrey à la trace qui
participera ce rendez-vous bonsoir
bonsoir lequel alors longtemps la boxe a
été un sport réservé aux hommes la boxe
mines a vraiment pris son essor dans les
années 90 et les premiers championnats
du monde et elles ont été organisées en
2001 aux états unis et les jaunes ont
inclus la boxe ming seulement en 2012 à
londres
c'est le sport idéal pour parler la
journée la femme la boxe c'est un très
bon sport parce que effectivement il est
assez peu féminisé et nous notre idée
c'est vraiment de faire découvrir au
public féminin et que les femmes osent
franchir la porte d'une salle de boxe
toujours un petit peu compliqué on a
l'impression que c'est très très
masculin alors qu'en fait on a tous
types de pratiques et les femmes peuvent
pratiquer faire et ce dès ce se faire
plaisir dans ce sport et on a de très
bons résultats en féminines aussi audrey
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de
franchira les portes d'une salle de boxe
oui c'est vrai que à nous si on n'avait
pas reçu le mail d'alban pour nous
proposer de partager son événement
l'association à l'association pégase et
de venir participer
c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque chose
que je pense que j'aurais fait
naturellement et elle serait que de voir
l'initiative dans le cadre de la journée
de la femme
on s'est dit on va passer le pas et on
va y aller c'est également un sport en
plein essor depuis les jo de 2016 avec
la france qui a remporté notamment une
médaille d'or par estelle mossely ya
actuellement à 50 6069 licenciés sur les
rings exactement pourquoi cet essor a
pris en france parce que alors en fait
comme vous comme vous l'avez dit la boxe
et olympique depuis 2012 est en fait
elle était pas très médiatisé en tout
cas la boxe féminine jusqu'à jusqu'à au
début des années 90 aux états unis et
puis ensuite ça s'est développé à partir
de 2016 avec les jeux olympiques de rio
médaille d'or des stades mousseline et
donc moins de 60 kg et puis médaille
d'argent de sarah ourahmoune moins de 51
pas vous a pas oublié cette belle
victoire aussi donc je crois que ça a
créé un engouement ça a contribué à
médiatiser et du coup ça ramener un
nouveau public sur le sur la boxe
anglaise le public public féminin 25 %
de licenciés en plus vous faites partie
de ces 25%
c'est ça qui vous a donné envie de vous
lancer ces jo de 2016 non je fais
absolument pas partie des licenciés pour
moi je dis sera vraiment une initiation
total initiation totalement vrai mais
c'est vrai que les victoires qui a eu au
dojo on ya pensé et je suivrai que je me
suis dit à ce moment là que ça pourrait
être un sport intéressant mais c'est
vrai que j'avais jamais franchi le cap -
vous sentez de dole enthousiasme autour
de cette discipline complètement ses
fins et c'est chez les filles que chez
les garçons
et oui c'est remarquable c'est à dire
que les femmes aujourd'hui on vraiment
vraiment cette envie de pratiquer et
c'est agréable pour nous en tant
qu'entraîneur parce que moi de mon
expérience je vais croiser des femmes
qui disaient j'aimerais bien boxé
j'aimerais bien essayer mais chose quoi
et j'ose pas parce que je suis une femme
et ça c'est vraiment dérangeant quand
quand le sexe devient discriminant et
cons et qu'on n'ose pas pratiqué parce
que parce qu'on est une femme
donc c'est vraiment il ya vraiment un
gros gros enthousiasme aujourd'hui et
c'est très très bien ça peut être que
positif pour la discipline
audrey la boxe est un sport fait pour
les hommes et pour les femmes
oui je pense je pense vraiment que ça
commence à se développer et que les
femmes ont vraiment envie d'y aller et
je pense qu'il ya moyen que on how i la
parité à un moment donné je pense
vraiment que ça se développe
la boxe est elle différente chez les
filles à votre avis je sais pas je vais
voir ça judiciaire
et oui alors oui en fait la pratique est
différente selon qu'on est un homme ou
une femme
les façons de pratiquer sont différentes
le type de pratique est différent on a
notamment une discipline qui s'appelle
l'aéroboxe qui qui réunit énormément de
licenciées féminines en termes de
pourcentage je crois qu'elles sont au
dessus de 80 % sur l'aéroboxe donc là on
est sur quelque chose dont on a pas
d'opposition
on va chercher du ried on va chercher du
cardio on va chercher de la condition
physique et on enlève le côté qui fait
un peu peur de prendre des coups et de
se retrouver en opposition donc la
pratique féminine est complètement
différente de la pratique masculine ils
recherchent des sensations différentes
également à bien que ça me wade tout à
fait les sensations sont différentes on
n'est plus sûr de la touche alors que
chez les hommes on va avoir tendance à
plus en plus frappée puis s'appuyer donc
c'est vraiment complètement différent et
c'est ce qui est intéressant aussi parce
qu'il ya une vraie complémentarité sur
le relais de pratiques et comment va se
dérouler secours justement alors on aura
un accueil à partir de 10 cas les filles
vont remonter sur le ring
18h50 et ben je crois que vous allez
venir avec une de vos collègues à monter
sur le ring
effectivement donc reprendre sa gelée
sera diffusé vendredi dans le 7-8 hebdo
tout à fait il y aura une démonstration
de
deux de nos adhérentes qui seront qui
sont également sur le ring et puis
ensuite ce sera vraiment une initiation
pour faire découvrir la discipline à des
personnes comme audrey et puis et puis
les autres participants qui seront là
donc on aura sur deux heures à peu près
tous les types de pratiques aéroboxe
boxe éducative boxe loisir travail au
sac de frappe travail aux pattes d'ours
gainage renforcement musculaire on a
vraiment un panel complet donc pendant
plusieurs heures pendant deux ans
désert pendant deux heures il va falloir
tenir donc soyez prêtes vous n'avez pas
trop peur d'aller sur ce stage
initiation
non mais c'est vraiment une découverte
et j'ai hâte de voir comment ça va se
passer
non je pense que ce sera vraiment dans
la bonne ambiance je m'inquiète très
fort ça ça va il faut les compétences
spécifiques pour s'inscrire
alors pour l'inscription pour le pour
l'initiation ou en général en boxe
anglaise pour à la boxe anglaise pour se
couvrir
alors pour ce cours là non parce que
l'idée c'est vraiment de faire découvrir
au public le plus large
et puis à des gens qui connaissent pas
forcément la discipline donc on va faire
découvrir ça si ça plait ensuite il faut
des qualités de cardio bonnes conditions
physiques d'explosivité
et puis surtout un bon mental c'est
quand même c'est quand même primordial
aussi audrey vous pensez vous avez
toutes ses qualités pour ce cours
absolument
est-ce qu'on peut encore s'inscrire ce
cas c'est encore des plats alors il va
probablement rester quelques places mais
là on est un peu victime
de l'engouement autour de l'événement
pour l'instant c'est complet parce que
pour des raisons de sécurité et puis de
deux places dans la salle où on veut
limiter le nombre de participantes
je pense qu'on va faire le point et que
probablement demain lors un petit quota
d'invitation qui sera qui sera réouvert
donc j'invite les personnes intéressées
à visiter le site et à regarder
il y aura d'autres événements c'est bien
sûr la voiture oui on va leur faire
enfin c'est extraordinaire de voir
comment l'intérêt qu'il peut y avoir
autour de ça donc on leur frein merci à
tous les deux est venu sur ce plateau
fort en un reportage complet comme vous
l'avez dit sur cet événement dans le
prochain à 7,8 hebdo également le
prochain à 7,8 sport c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]